all right welcome to the definitive
iPhone versus Android video it's The
Impossible debate right in a lot of ways
people just get so entrenched on one
side that they never want to flip to the
other side to each their own you hear
that all the time
but I have a solution
so here's how we're going to do this so
I'm going to break this down into seven
actually meaningful categories so it's
an odd number so there has to be a
winner no tie but since we're not
psychos and we know that one winner
doesn't automatically apply to every
human on earth I'm actually going to
give you a system a rubric to help
figure out the real winner for yourself
you'll see what I mean
let's get into it so all right category
number one customization basically if
you see this icon and you get excited
then you probably love customization too
so digging into the settings and messing
around with the home screen and the lock
screen and tweaking things and behaviors
to make the device absolutely perfect
for you
yeah it means a hobby all on its own now
at first in 2023 it might actually seem
like iOS 17 and Android 14 are pretty
close right I mean let's be real iOS
just added a bunch of really good
features that are very well done the new
lock screen update gives you the ability
to change all these clock fonts and
colors and put various super useful
widgets on your lock screen and then
save a bunch of different lock screen
setups for different situations and
different Focus modes and then widgets
were also added to the home screen less
than two years ago as well so that
unlocked a ton of customization of home
screen setups displaying glanceable
information but the more you look into
it the more you realize
it's not actually that close and a lot
of this really just comes down to the
fact that Apple they do keep adding all
these abilities but you're always
restricted to doing it the Apple Way the
correct way and so that's why a lot of
iPhone setups still just kind of look
the same like even if you just take
stock Android 14 from the Google pixel
which isn't even the most customizable
version of Android there's still way
more that you can change from the colors
of the theme of the OS matching the
color of your wallpaper thanks to
material U to icon packs custom widget
sizes I mean Android will just kind of
let you do whatever you want on the
iPhone you can't expand a widget to any
size you want you can't put an app just
on the right side of your home screen
for reachability you literally can't
even place an app wherever you want on
the home screen it must be the next up
in the grid of Apple's choosing you
can't change the grid size you can't
change the icon sizes I mean it just
takes a whole bunch of extra work and a
series shortcuts hack just to use a
custom icon just basic stuff now I think
the other side of that coin is you can
make a truly ugly horrible android setup
where you can't really mess up an iPhone
home screen that much so while you can
definitely argue that iOS does it
prettier the winner for most
customization that would be Android so
then category number two features all
right just straight up which one can do
more stuff this has been one of the
hottest debates at the Forefront of iOS
versus Android conversation Joe is here
mostly because both platforms at some
level launched missing features but
especially the iPhone like you'd always
hear wow can you believe the iPhone
can't even set wallpapers and then it
was can you believe the iPhone is just
now getting copy and paste seriously and
then it's wow it's crazy that iOS is
just getting widgets now a decade later
but hey now it's 2023 and they're both
very complete and even in the ways that
they're not they're They're copying each
other all the time you always see a new
keynote with new stuff on Android and
you're like that came from IOS and then
you'll see stuff from the iPhone key
note be like that came from Android but
there's even some new stuff now that the
iPhone has that Android doesn't a pretty
good one recently is focus modes which
gives you super high control over
notifications in various different
situations with your apps and your
contacts there are also a lot of privacy
features things like hide my email with
iCloud plus and iCloud private relay you
could even argue that Dynamic Island on
the pro iPhone is a feature if you want
to but I mean I just I couldn't because
only a small handful of apps support it
but it's something pretty cool and
unique which is more and more rare than
ever in the smartphone world at this
point though neither OS is really
missing any gigantic features anymore
they both matured up to this level where
they're their own character they both do
a lot of stuff
but I still am going to have to give the
edge
to Android in this one just because
there are so many little like Tweaky
like little OS level features just
little things that you can tweak and
change on Android that still just are
not on the iPhone so I'm talking like
battery management features to customize
charging speeds or set manual charge
limits to preserve battery life there's
also an actual file management system so
you can drag and drop things onto your
phone into certain folders if you want
to there's gaming specific features like
game modes the ability to dial up and
down your screen's refresh rate whenever
you want to Independent volume controls
for phone calls and ringtones and alarms
also reverse wireless charging comes up
a lot for charging wireless earbuds
without breaking out a separate cable
really that just it comes down to the
the benefit of Android is having so much
feature Choice that's kind of the point
and this also bleeds into Hardware too
so even if the feature you want is a
huge camera with no notch
then you have to get an Android phone
right so if the feature is a super fast
charging or a 10x camera or USB type c
as of right now
it's got to be an Android phone so even
though they both offer all the basic
features and they appear to copy each
other all the time on little added stuff
the winner here again is definitely
Android now number three is ease of use
now ease of use is very valuable to a
lot of people like a lot of people and
the thing about ease of use is it often
basically has an inverse relationship
with customization and a ton of features
because there's this delicate Balancing
Act you have to do of having flexibility
giving flexibility to the user but not
overwhelming them with a ton of buttons
and settings and this is really where
the iPhone excels and has excelled for
years as a high priority for sure even
in the most fundamental ways the home
screen on the iPhone has had up to four
icons in the dock on every iPhone since
the beginning and the phone icon has
always been green and always been on the
left every single time for 17 years the
iPhone's camera app we've all seen that
stay fundamentally the same with the
viewfinder and the sliding modes it's
been like that for years and that kind
of tucks away a lot of the settings into
a separate Settings app and it can feel
like it's missing features but honestly
it's still the easiest and most
straightforward for most people to use
it's like they hate changing things for
no good reason the calculator has
basically been unchanged for years now
there's also downsides to that like Siri
has basically been ignored since it was
introduced but still like apple moves
the call end button by like 200 pixels
to the middle of the screen and people
freak out about it sometimes it feels
like Android versions will just move
stuff around just kind of to try it and
for the sake of changing things and
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
they'll move it back and that's
interesting and exciting sometimes but
that does hurt just user continuity and
ease of use maybe not for you watching
this video but just think for the
average person like for your five
closest friends think about how they use
their phone
yeah then throw on top of that there's
basically never any bloatware loaded
onto the iPhone ever and then customer
service is basically always better for
an iPhone because Apple stores are
everywhere and apple controls that
entire experience For Better or For
Worse so they get to do great work with
customers so it's just for people who
are not enthusiasts who just want to get
the thing and not think about it anymore
they pretty much always go with the
iPhone so ease of use is a checkbox for
the iPhone by the way if you're enjoying
this video get subscribed why not it's
free all right so we gotta talk about
updates so number four is support so
this is something that I would classify
as kind of underrated just because I
don't think enough people buy their new
phone that they plan on having for years
with this in mind I think having the
latest and greatest updates software and
security patches as quick as possible
and as long as possible
should be a priority but it usually
isn't for people either way it's kind of
a mixed bag across the board in Android
World some companies make no promises or
they kind of break their promises some
have short promises and some will
actually extend out to promising three
to four years of software updates
weirdly Samsung right now is the
Undisputed king of Android software
updates with some rumors of maybe Google
catching back up but Samsung announced
in 2019 that all devices in 2019 or
later will get four years of security
updates and some flagships live and get
five
but none of them really come close to
the iPhone when iOS 17 comes out this
fall every iPhone back to the iPhone 10r
from 2018 is officially supported and
going to get the latest version that's
five major software version updates I
don't think there are any Android phones
from 2018 that are going to get the
latest version of Android 14 when it
comes out so this one easily goes to the
vertically integrated Apple phone with
the Apple software all day so now my
number five category is apps
this one is actually kind of fascinating
so obviously we have our our standard
like our apps that we all use every
single day on our phones that we're used
to but then sometimes it's fun just sort
of popping around in their respective
app stores discovering new things
finding fun apps and at this point they
are both flourishing there's millions of
apps now it's over three and a half
million apps in the Google Play Store
and over a million and a half in Apple's
app store which if you just stop there
looks like a win for Android but
quality over quantity my friends quality
over quantity basically every major app
is available for both platforms which
means there are many more you know Niche
apps or relatively unknown possible
diamonds on the rough on the Google Play
Store sure but the difference is when
you actually talk to these developers
and observe the cycle of like how they
get made and how these apps get updated
the truth is
so many of them are prioritizing iOS and
really it's purely for efficiency think
about it if you just have to update one
version of your app and it works with
all the newest iPhones instantly and
works perfectly for millions of people
who all have basically the same aspect
ratio of course you'd do it flip that
switch but with Android there are
naturally many more complexities there
are a bunch of different devices that
all have different aspect ratios and
different pixel densities and different
feature support and even foldables and
it's like it's a lot more work to get
all of those users up to date with the
same level of optimization it's a lot of
different switches to flip so a lot of
them just don't go through all of that
or they take way longer to so the number
of titles is one thing but is it the
same Instagram app on both iPhone and
Android is it the same threads app on
each one as someone who's been carrying
and using both phones and often using
the same app on both phones I have a
first-hand experience of knowing that
often even with some of Google's own
apps the updates are prioritized on the
iPhone they come first to the iPhone
before they come to Android I wish that
wasn't true I wish they were just as
easy to do one or the other but that's
just the truth of it so the slight app
Advantage is going to go to the iPhone
here and interestingly enough this also
applies generally to accessories again
same reason same efficiency but that's a
win for the iPhone so then category
number six I'm gonna go a little more
subjective with this one but I still
think it matters which is excitement
which one is more interesting or
exciting in the moment to you now
honestly I get pretty excited for a lot
of different new tech these days and
actually because there's only like one
or two new iPhone drops every year it's
actually very easy to get hype built up
for the new iPhone but it's definitely a
different type of excitement with the
massive variety of new Innovations and
things that come to Android phones all
the time like if you just are interested
in folding phones well there's more
Android releases than ever for that want
a gaming phone there's going to be an
Android for that do you want a headphone
jack do you want a compact phone do you
want the world's fastest charging do you
want some interesting new Unique Designs
or materials or textures or experimental
features like that is the world of
Android and if you think about it
seriously think about this most of the
interesting excitement around every new
iPhone launch the question really is is
this new iPhone going to get a new
feature that's been in Android phones
for years like are we finally going to
get USBC on an iPhone are we finally
going to get fast charging on an iPhone
are we are we finally going to get a 5x
camera
and so just for that novelty reason
alone the excitement category that's
definitely got to go to Android so that
brings us to my last category number
seven
ecosystem we've heard this word before
ecosystem so okay say what you want but
there are a lot of people
who will not buy a phone if it doesn't
have
iMessage or FaceTime whatever it is and
Apple has like weaponized this and built
walls around this and close it off as
much as possible technically you can
join a FaceTime from an Android phone
but can't start one so I made an entire
video just about Apple's ecosystem hated
or love it it is important to some
people now the thing is Apple is not the
only one with an ecosystem like look at
Samsung for example Apple happens to
build bigger walls around keeping people
into their ecosystem but Samsung has a
lot of equivalence to all the same
pieces like you could get a Samsung
Galaxy S Flagship and you could quickly
and easily connect your Galaxy buds just
like airpods you put on your Galaxy
watch with a lot of the same features as
the Apple watch you tether to a Samsung
Tab just for entertainment purposes like
an iPad but then you get a Galaxy Book
Pro with cellular internet sharing and
wireless Quick Share just like a MacBook
Pro with airdrop you see where I'm going
it just keeps going and going I'm sure
Samsung is eventually going to come out
with their smart speaker to match the
homepod totally totally coming but on
paper the idea is they are surprisingly
congruent so the way I see it at the
time of this recording because this
could change very soon in the next
couple weeks but the main advantages of
Samsung's ecosystem would be things like
one USBC across literally everything so
you can use one charging cable for all
of your stuff two they make more
different versions of devices that fit
into the ecosystem like there are a ton
of different phones and a bunch of
different watches and different
headphones and laptops Etc so there's
more flexibility and Hardware Choice
classic Android plus Samsung also makes
other stuff that connects like
dishwashers and refrigerators but then
the advantages of Apple's ecosystem not
just in the US but especially here are
first of all ease of use and
seamlessness like it is genuinely crazy
how good some of the continuity stuff is
in Apple's ecosystem like something like
continuity camera is so sick every time
you just push one button to use a super
high quality iPhone camera as their web
cam it works very very well but then the
popularity Factor especially in the US
makes things like FaceTime and iMessage
and the find my network super strong so
I can make a whole video on this I could
put up the strengths and weaknesses and
put up these just these two ecosystems
up against each other but as of right
now they're both very strong and I'm
going to give the slight Edge to Apples
just because one I'm in the US and that
Advantage is strong but two just because
of the seamlessness and how well things
are integrated and the continuity
features are unreal so if we tally these
all up here you can see that the
objective winner and four out of the
seven categories that I made up is the
iPhone but but put your pitchforks down
guess what
there is no as you've probably picked up
from the beginning of this video there
is no objective winner to a decision as
personal as this one and when the
options are this close you probably
already know if you've been watching my
videos you know I'm Main and Android
phone most of the time alongside
an iPhone but my main phone and my main
customized setups are on the Android
phone so what gives like picking one de
facto winner kind of suggests that the
one winner is best for everyone but we
already know that people there's some
people who literally don't care about
some features that some others would say
they can't live without so I've devised
a very basic system to help you pick
your winner for yourself and it's really
quite simple all you have to do is put
these seven categories in order of
importance to you
and then rate each one of them let's say
on a scale from one to five so give them
a one to five point rating based on how
much you care about it so here for me I
care the most about customization and
features then I care a lot about apps
and excitement and updates are decently
important but then in my daily driver
ease of use and ecosystem aren't that
big of a deal I've got a mixed bag so
then I just give the amount of points
earned to each winner of that category
so the winner for me is clearly Android
but hey for you maybe uh maybe you care
a lot about ecosystem and maybe nothing
else I'm sure you know someone like this
then the iPhone will clearly be calling
your name or if you're the type who
wants all the features and excitement in
the world well then Android probably is
what's in your pocket you might even
have your own category you could add in
that's heavily weighted I kind of see it
like buying a car like maybe cool
factors in there have at it it turns out
buying a phone is one of the most
personal decisions you make I've said
this before but like it's the thing you
spent your money on and you carry
everywhere you go and that's why people
get so worked up about this side versus
that side but at the end of the day the
winner not to be cheesy
is us because they're competing against
each other to get better to hopefully
win you over
and that's the way it should be
thanks for watching
catch the next one
peace
[Music]